[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo les quiero pedir que lentamente se
retiren el antifaz
que abra sus ojos lentamente también que
abran sus que despierten sus sentidos y
adicionalmente que abran sus mentes y
quiero comenzar con una historia
real
de una mujer que en su primer embarazo
estaba en medio de una operación cesárea
como lo ven allí y cuando nace el niño
se lo entrega al obstetra se lo entrega
al pediatra el pediatra rápidamente
empieza a limpiarlo y atenderlo y de
pronto se le acerca a la madre en medio
de la cesárea por un lado y le dice
señora mire a su bebé evidentemente la
señora le dijo muy lindo mi bebé muchas
gracias doctor y el doctor la intérprete
dice mire lo bien y obviamente la señora
se sorprende un poco y le pregunta qué
pasa y ella el médico le dice a su bebé
es mongólico y la señora le pregunta y
eso que es doctor y ella le dice y él le
dice no tengo mucho tiempo para
explicarle porque tengo que llevarlo a
la unidad porque le falta oxígeno pero
lo que le puedo decir es que su bebé es
un vegetal no le va a servir de mucho
pero hay que darle mucho amor y
desapareció el quirófano evidentemente
la señora con una noticia de ese tamaño
quedó en shock los cirujanos tuvieron
que alan
decía general para terminar la cesárea
porque las noticias de la banda donde la
cesárea y luego yo tuve la oportunidad
de conocerla a ella ya su familia la
señora nunca amamantó a su bebé no lo
tocó nunca quedó de psiquiatra por la
reunión por la noticia y adicionalmente
durante años vi cómo el padre atendía a
su hijo para todas las actividades que
había que hacer pero también tenía que
llevar a su señora que quedó con
enfermedad mental muy seria durante años
por la manera como se le da la noticia y
evidentemente dar noticias
es un arte muchas veces piensan que
nosotros los médicos tenemos la
habilidad de dar noticia y nos toca
comunicar frecuentemente noticias pero
es un arte que no lo enseñan en la
universidad usualmente se aprende con la
vida sobre todo cuando no tiene que
comunicar noticias y yo creo que para
dar una noticia se requieren dos
elementos básicos uno es tener
conocimientos sobre lo que vamos a
comunicar evidentemente y lo segundo es
tener empatía y tener empatía es tener
la capacidad de sentir
e imaginar lo que siente la persona que
está recibiendo la noticia para poder
adaptar nuestra nuestra nuestro proceso
de comunicación
y quiero comenzar con un ejemplo si yo
los invito a ustedes imaginemos que
estamos todos embarazados en este
momento las chicas todas están
embarazadas y los caballeros obviamente
estamos embarazados en pareja siempre
creemos que las embarazadas son ellas y
realmente somos en pareja los que
estamos embarazados e imaginemos que
estamos en embarazo todos y una de las
preguntas que nos vamos a hacer cuando
estamos esperando un nuevo bebé es
doctor doctora cuénteme mi bebé viene
bien y es una pregunta frecuente que
hacemos todos los humanos cuando estamos
en esa condición le estamos pidiendo al
médico oa la persona que nos atiende que
nos cuente cómo viene nuestro bebé y yo
le cuento para empezar la historia le
cuento a las las parejas que quieren
esta información les digo imagínense que
ustedes todos se encuentran en un
hospital los llevo a la sala de recién
nacidos y allí les pongo la tarea de
contar
cuántos niños nacieron bien y cuántos
nacieron con uno o con muchas
diferencias con defectos uno o muchos
imagínense que los invito a ir cuatro
meses todos los días al hospital y a los
cuatro meses ustedes se van a dar cuenta
de una cifra mágica el 3 por ciento de
los seres humanos nacen o nacemos con
alguna diferencia si el 3 por ciento de
los humanos tenemos una diferencia eso
significa que 1 de cada 33 niños tiene
algo y esa tal vez es una cifra más
tangible porque significa que el día que
estemos embarazados en pareja vamos a
tener 32 oportunidad de 33 de que
nuestro hijo esté sano pero también
vamos a tener una oportunidad de 33 de
que nuestro hijo tenga alguna diferencia
y lo que le digo a esa pareja cuando va
a comunicar la noticia es que si nos
toca uno de los 32 niños de 33 que viene
sano magnífico eso es lo que soñamos
todos que nuestros hijos nazcan bien
pero si nuestro hijo es aquel que tiene
una muchas diferencias muchas
variaciones
y ese magnífico magnífico porque nuestro
hijo no tiene la culpa no ha elegido
nacer así sus padres tampoco y lo que él
está esperando de nosotros o ella es que
lo recibamos con afecto con aprecio con
amor con mucha pasión y le ayudemos a
tratar de superar los problemas con los
cuales ha nacido entonces yo creo que
todos los humanos aceptaríamos mejor a
aquellas personas que nacen con
diferencias con variaciones si todos
tuviéramos este conocimiento tan
elemental que 1 de cada 33 humanos que
nacemos en este planeta tenemos derecho
a ser distintos y evidentemente son
muchos y uno de cada 33 hermanos del
planeta es diferente pues somos muchas
personas y les quiero mostrar los
ejemplos sencillos uno de cada 300 niños
tiene por ejemplo un dedo extra en las
manos o los pies eso se llama
polidactilia es un defecto común uno de
cada 300 niños tiene una bolita de carne
delante de la oreja un apéndice
auricular uno de cada 300 personas tiene
un hoyuelo delante de la oreja o uno de
400 tiene luxación de la cadera ustedes
ven en la imagen la cadera
izquierda
con una luxación es un defecto muy común
usted los han visto uno de 400 personas
tiene un pie desviado hacia adentro esos
son ejemplos de efectos comunes y uno de
cada 400 personas tiene una ayuda en la
base del hueso sacro en la espalda y
estos son defectos comunes
lo cual significa que a cualquiera de
nosotros en cualquiera de nuestros hijos
podría ocurrir una de estas condiciones
una de cada 600 personas tiene una
microtia o una oreja que no se
desarrolla y evidentemente va a tener
sordera del lado donde tenga la micro
tía o eventualmente de las dos de los
dos lados y ustedes también los han
visto en la calle una de cada 600
personas tiene una gran mancha en algún
lugar de su cuerpo es un defecto común y
una de cada 745 personas es una hermosa
persona con síndrome de down y muchas
veces como fue este ejemplo que les
conté con la madre que recibe a su bebé
en la cesárea y le cuenta que tiene
síndrome down el síndrome no es muy
común el día que ustedes estén
embarazados en pareja van a tener una
oportunidad de 745 en cada embarazo
les llegue a sus familias a su prole una
persona con síndrome down porque nace en
síndrome de personas con síndrome dan
por un accidente y accidente donde
ocurre en los ovarios o en los
testículos porque ustedes saben que
todos los humanos tenemos 46 cromosomas
pero cada óvulo espermatozoide que
producimos trae 23 lo cual significa que
sus ovarios sus testículos y los míos se
la pasan restando miles de veces o
millones de veces de 46 a 23 porque cada
vez permita soy de okada o de través la
mitad y porque nace un niño con síndrome
down porque uno de sus padres
accidentalmente como ven allá a la
derecha en la imagen accidentalmente le
entregó 24 cromosomas en vez de 23
significa que el accidente que causa el
síndrome de dawn ocurre en nuestros
testículos o en nuestros ovarios cuando
restamos de 46 a 23 millones de veces en
el caso de los hombres o miles de veces
en el caso de las mujeres y
evidentemente esto es un accidente
entonces hay que contar con conocimiento
a las personas porque nacemos con alguna
diferencia de la explicación
a contribuir de manera importante eso y
porque uno de cada 800 personas tiene
fisura de labio y paladar si supiéramos
que entre las 6 y las 8 semanas de
embarazo nuestra cara se forma de dos
placas que van viajando hacia adelante
una placa que baja con la nariz y este
par de cicatrices que tenemos todos bajo
la cara y la prueba de que nuestra cara
cerró a tiempo a las 8 semanas una
persona como esta con fisura de labio y
paladar es una persona que se atrasó una
placa o las dos placas en juntarse con
la del centro y le quedó una hendidura o
ventana eventualmente dos hendiduras
esto también es un defecto común que
tiene que ver con diferentes genes que
contribuyen al desarrollo de nuestra
cara en un momento crítico al inicio del
embarazo y uno de cada 1.500 niños nace
con defectos de corazón
algunos son operables otros no
uno de cada cinco mil personas tiene
estatura muy baja
y evidentemente puedo pasar la tarde
citando más ejemplos entonces primera
idea para comunicar una noticia
evidentemente tener conocimiento porque
lo que está esperando la persona que
recibe la noticia es que es que lo que
le cuenten sea cierto y que tenga un
apoyo una explicación y para hablar de
la empatía o la capacidad de entender
cómo piensa y cómo siente la persona que
está recibiendo la información voy a
usar un ejemplo de unos indígenas
mexicanos que son los tarahumaras
también se llaman rarámuris ramón y
significa corredores y estos indígenas
viven en los desiertos de mexico que
limitan con los desiertos de eeuu los
desiertos de eeuu los conocemos todos
arizona nevada california texas los de
méxico son menos conocidos son los
mismos desiertos durango zacatecas
sinaloa chihuahua son los mismos
desiertos se os viene el noroccidente de
méxico y estos indígenas tienen unas
características especiales
la primera es que son muy elegantes
miren esas mujeres los trajes que usan
son evidentemente más elegantes que los
propios que estamos usando nosotros en
este momento
y tiene una manera muy interesante de
ver a los hijos los tarahumaras cuando
nace un niño o niña que luce sano sin
variaciones o defectos o anomalías sus
dos papás y la comunidad tarahumara
donde nace el niño hacen una fiesta de
un día en la cual oa través de la cual
aceptan al niño entre todos lo ayudan a
criar colectivamente con una paternidad
colectiva de todos los adultos para que
esa persona llega a adulto no fallezca
por enfermedades típicas del no
desarrollo la pobreza lo que sea y tiene
una manera muy particular de cuidar a
sus hijos con una gran fiesta lo reciben
de un solo día los hombres tarahumaras
también son más elegantes que nosotros
los pueden ver allí claramente
pero cuando nace un niño con variaciones
con diferencias los aromas no hacen
fiesta hacen una gran fiesta que demora
siete días que coincide más o menos con
nuestra semana santa pero no la hacen en
el desierto donde ellos viven sino que
la hacen en las montañas de la sierra
madre occidental mexicana donde tienen
que viajar aproximadamente 250
kilómetros y no la hace la comunidad
donde nació el niño sino van todos los
tarahumaras esta es la segunda migración
humana más grande en el planeta por
después de la migración musulmana a la
meca 59 mil a 60 mil personas viajan una
vez al año 250 kilómetros para reunirse
en las montañas en un lugar especial que
no es el lugar donde ellos viven es un
lugar de ceremonias donde se casan donde
discuten cosas importantes pero
adicionalmente allí hacen la fiesta para
sus niños o niñas que nacen con alguna
diferencia este templo grande que ven a
su izquierda es el templo le llaman
ellos de la vida y uno de los pequeños
que estacionado
le llaman el templo de la muerte cuando
llegan al lugar ellos tienen también su
sistema de salud sus médicos su chamán
que usa todos sus conocimientos para
tratar de mejorar la condición de salud
que tienen los tarahumaras reparan el
lugar porque ha estado abandonado un año
completo ellos no viven ahí y hacen
preparativos como ven allí hasta que
está completamente reparado utilizan y
le ponen sus trajes muy especiales y
ellos ven se visten de manera elegante
aquí usan los trajes espléndidos mucho
más
elegantes recogen un cactus que se llama
peyote y el peyote es un alucinógeno
parecido al lsd y lo ingieren pero
digieren tres días de esa fiesta y son
los únicos tres días en los cuales todos
consumen peyote porque necesitan
drogarse por decirlo así y comunicarse
con sus dioses pero créanme jóvenes que
lo hacen sólo tres días del año no todos
los viernes ni todas las fiestas ni
todos los días solamente lo hacen 33
días del año porque necesitan
comunicarse con sus dioses y el peyote
les ayuda en esa conexión ahí están en
el proceso del consumo del peyote tienen
músicos y cantadores que durante tres
días y sus noches 24 horas o tocan
música o cantan evidentemente y los que
no hacen estas dos actividades los demás
bailan y hacen un baile muy monótono que
parte del templo de la vida al templo la
muerte y luego regresan lo cual
significa que él cree en la
reencarnación seguramente pero son baile
muy monótono que yo les quiero pedir
ustedes que lo tratemos de imitar por lo
tanto quienes no tengan dificultades de
movilidad ni equilibrio
les pido el favor que se levanten en un
segundo con mucho cuidado traten de
quitar los objetos que tengan a su
alrededor que puedan causar una caída y
vamos a hacer una danza monótona vamos a
imaginar que vamos del templo de la vida
al templo de la muerte y es una danza
monótona que la hacen tres días y sus
noches drogados con pelotas etcétera es
ésta hacen dos pasos adelante una media
vuelta a ver dos pasos adelante o al
lado si quieren para media vuelta y
luego un paso atrás y vamos a través de
dos pasos adelante media vuelta un paso
atrás y luego imagínense dos pasos
adelante media vuelta un paso atrás
durante tres días y sus noches drogados
con peyote pero se respetan sientes de
por favor se respetan se aprecian se
quieren y reciben con honor y con
orgullo a sus niños y niñas que traen
una variación una diferencia eso
significa piense que es lo contrario a
nuestra cultura cuando yo me acerco a
dar una noticia a una familia
le han llegado un niño que tiene una
diferencia una variación
los encuentro tristes normalmente
llorosos con la habitación a oscuras no
hay flores no hay muñecos etcétera
nuestro sistema de salud tampoco los
acoge la preparada no les va a afiliar
porque traen una preexistencia les toca
meter tutelas y demás para tratar de que
se reciban los servicios de salud que
tienen defensa que tenemos que aprender
de los tarahumaras y tenemos que
aprender los tarahumaras en el sentido
de que ellos nos están mostrando la gran
capacidad que tienen la flexibilidad en
su cerebro para atender a las personas
que tienen alguna diferencia alguna
variación porque finalmente si una de
cada 33 humanos tenemos una variación
una diferencia pues somos muchos si
tomamos a las personas mi ejemplo del
síndrome de dawn una década 745 y
calculamos que siete mil millones de
humanos en este momento serían nueve
millones de personas o sea que podríamos
ocupar con ellos una ciudad como bogotá
lima eventualmente guadalajara etcétera
y entonces si todos estuvieran en ese
lugar los que no tenemos síndrome de
dawn seríamos los diferentes y lo que
nos gustaría es que fuéramos aceptados
en la misma condición si fuéramos los
nosotros distintos y fuéramos la minoría
evidentemente entonces es la danza tres
días felices y quiero terminar
simplemente con esta frase que es del
libro de ernesto sábato antes del fin en
donde el escritor nos dice solo quiénes
de nosotros seamos capaces de sostener
la utopía lo que parece imposible
son las personas aptas para el combate
decisivo y el combate decisivo de
recuperar cuanto de humanidad hemos
perdido
[Música]